tu sais qui je suis je suis la solution
au problème je débarrasse les ordures je
fais partir ces taches tenaces
voyons ça comme ça je suis quelqu'un de
sociable
le boulot est fait du tatouage la seule
raison pour avoir un coéquipier c'est
vrai vrai papa tout va bien mon
coéquipier se fait descendre
il m'avait donné sa parole tu te retires
est de ce métier c'est la dernière fois
je referai plus jamais ça tel le coin
police de washington
je trouvais que ça sentait beaucoup le
flic ça m'intéresse pas d'engager un
tueur à gages de table je veux les gars
qui ont descendu votre coéquipier
vous allez faire quoi apporter le
champion de kung-fu directement deux
pays je suis né en floride
j'engage des gens comme vous pour
éliminer l'ennemi
boudebouz est cinglé vous affrontez un
ancien mercenaire il va vous bousillé et
je vais le regarder faire
on tue par le casse ont raison elle
vient de le faire
ça y est
et tu négocies une chose que tu veux
papa je te jure quand je vais avoir ce
gars là ça va faire mal
jacques a biffé
ça dérangerait beaucoup quand on écoute
la musique de ce siècle
je vais pas te laisser faire une crise
de folie meurtrière tu commences à
sonner comme un indice que les enfants
même plus des 10 ça existe plus génial
toi et moi on a une petite affaire en
suspens à régler est ce que tu vas pas
trop bien tu vas m'ennuie à mourir
je sais tu me l'a déjà dit on aurait dû
l'embarqué ne fait confiance à personne
c'est comme ça qu'on reste dans le
métier
bang à terre arrivé